Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome back to our orthodontic series and this will be our
final video where we go through 15 practice questions that test what you learned from
the orthodontic series.
So this is everything that we talked about and if you haven't already, I definitely recommend
you to go back and watch the full series before attempting these questions.
You can really test what you learned and I broke down the material covered on the board
exam into 11 videos of high yield information and this information will really help you
on the board exam.
So I compiled 15 questions, let's go through those right now.
So question number one, which of the following statements is correct?
Go ahead, read through the answers, pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
So this is a growth and development type of question and it's asking about the types
of ossification that the different bones of the craniofacial complex are created from.
So let's go through starting with the cranial vault because that's what I've talked about
first in our video series.
The cranial vault is formed by intra membranous ossification and that's at the fontanels and
the sutures as well as the internal and external surfaces.
So this is certainly not endocondrel, there's no cartilage in the cranial vault.
The cranial base consists of the ethmoid, sphenoid and occipital bones at the skull base and those
are initially in cartilage, then they ossify into bones leaving behind synchondroses between
those bones and then we get endocondrel ossification at those synchondroses through childhood and
adulthood.
So there's also technically some intermembranous growth at the surfaces of these bones in a lateral
direction but primarily this is endocondrel.
It's certainly not intermembranous only though so this one is a little bit tricky but if
that were to be correct I would want to see both endocondrel and intermembranous for
the cranial base.
And then for the maxilla, intramembranous ossification occurs at the sutures posterior
and superior to the maxilla and also to remodel the surfaces.
So intramembranous is true but it's not endocondrel because there's no cartilage in the maxilla
so that's also incorrect.
So we're left with A and the mandible grows by both intermembranous and endocondrel ossification
that is in fact correct.
So intermembranous ossification is used to correct to create the corpus where the body
and the ramus embryologically and then endocondrel ossification is used to create the condular
cartilage embryologically and then both forms of ossification continue through childhood
and adulthood.
Endocondrel at the condyle, intermembranous at the surfaces everywhere else.
So the correct answer for question number one is A.
Alright question number two, a child in the primary dentition is most likely to have which
of the following clinical presentations.
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
So most young children especially before the age of three present with minimal overbite
or slight open bite in the primary dentition.
The key here is primary dentition and that's because habits are very very common at this
age like thumb sucking or using a pacifier which can contribute to a reduced overbite.
But that's only temporary that's not something that's going to hold through the mixed dentition
and permanent dentition unless that habit stays constant throughout those years.
So primary dentition, it's okay to see a decreased or reduced overbite that's somewhat normal
and so that is something that we would likely see in the clinical presentation of a child
if we're seeing them that early on.
So a child in the primary dentition, this is a pretty typical appearance where we have
very minimal overbite between those primary incisors, it's either decreased, reduced or
maybe even slightly open.
So the answer here is B.
All right question number three, a patient with trisomy 21 will usually have all of the
following except go ahead pause the video and then we'll talk about this.
So trisomy 21 is a relatively common genetic disease it's caused by non disjunction which
leads to an extra chromosome number 21.
So we have three 21 chromosomes and it's correlated with a certain phenotype.
So down syndrome consists of certain phenotypic features that we might expect.
Maxillary hypoplasia is one of them, up slanted eyes is another, relative macroglosia is an
interesting term.
So it's not true macroglosia which would mean the tongue is just really, really big.
But the tongue is big relative to the small maxilla and small overall mouth, that's a
typical down syndrome patient may have.
So that is also true.
So we can rule out so far A and C. And we also talked about up slanted eyes, the palpebral
fissures, the openings of the eyes, so D is also true.
So if we're looking for the exception, high carries risk is not correlated with this syndrome.
Used peridontal disease risk, yes, but not high carries risk.
So the answer for this question is B.
Question number four, when class three elastics are used, the maxillary first molars experience
movement in what direction or directions.
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll talk about this.
Alright so this question comes down to understanding force vectors and specifically understanding
the force vectors that are applied with certain rubber band patterns.
So let's review that very briefly.
And I know I'm flashing the answer here, but I definitely want to show you some of these
pictures.
So class three elastics are used by stretching a rubber band from anterior tooth in the lower
arch, usually the canine, to a posterior tooth in the upper arch, usually the first molar.
And we know when a rubber band is stretched, it pulls on both ends.
So we can draw our force vector towards the center of that rubber band because it's going
to be pulling in both directions.
If we break that vector for this first molar into x and y axes, we have a mesial pull in
the x axis and an extrusive pull in the y axis.
So that maxillary first molar is experiencing both a mesial and an extrusive force.
So the answer here is B.
Now just to review for class two elastics, again used by stretching a rubber band, this
time from an anterior tooth in the upper arch, usually the canine, and a posterior tooth
in the lower arch, usually the first molar.
So here, the molar would be experiencing a mesial force and an extrusive force that much
is the same.
Both cases for the canine, they're going to be experiencing distal force and an extrusive
force.
What changes is which arch is being affected.
So inter-archalastics will always apply an extrusive force, but the mesial first distal
depends on the direction that you're running those elastics and to which teeth you're running
those elastics.
So for this example, and this question, the answer is B, as we saw in this image right
here.
All right, question number five, what occlusion is present when the mesial buckle cusp of the
permanent maxillary first molar is mesial to the buckle groove of the permanent mandibular
first molar in centric relation.
Go ahead, pause the video, and then we'll talk about this one.
So this question is testing your understanding of the angle classification system for permanent
molars.
Now class one occlusion means that the mesial buckle cusp of that maxillary first molar
is occluding with the buckle groove of the mandibular first molar.
Those two things should be locking together.
That's the correct molar relationship for ideal function and stability.
Now we're class two, if that upper molar is too far forward relative to the lower.
We're class three, if the upper molar is too far back relative to the lower.
So in this case, that maxillary first molar is mesial.
Another way to say that is too far forward.
So it's too far, if it's too far forward of where it's supposed to be, that means that
a class two molar relationship.
We can see that here.
This is a class one where they're locking in nicely.
Class two, where this is too far forward, class three where it's too far back.
This is explaining a class two dental situation.
So the answer is B. It's not true that any of these are possible.
In this specific example, that is in fact explaining a class two relationship.
Now it doesn't matter how much it's mesial to it.
They're not asking if it's a full cusp, class two or a half cusp, class two.
It's just asking if it's class two.
Alright question number six, what is the typical order of removing teeth if serial extraction
is chosen as the treatment to alleviate severe crowding?
Go ahead and pause the video and then we'll go through this together.
Alright so for serial extraction, remember one key memory tool and that's CD4 which is
conveniently also the name of that glycoprotein found on the surface of T helper cells.
So if you can remember CD4, you know all you need to for these kinds of questions.
So we know C, the C's refers to the primary canines in our ortholingo so we can rule out
that one, we can rule out this one and we have primary canines here and here, that's
good.
D's refer to primary first molars so we have that in B, whoops we're definitely not taking
out the permanent canines and then for the fors are the permanent first premolars.
So permanent is certainly doesn't need to be said, it's kind of understood but we have
the permanent first premolars there, perfect, B is exactly what we're looking for and that's
the correct answer.
Alright question number seven, which of the following synchondroses closes last?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
Alright so this is one of those kind of recapitulation questions, do we know it or don't we know
it?
And the synchondroses have some interesting names here but they're mostly in reference
to where they're located along the cranial base and in between which bones they are.
So the intersphenoid synchondroses closes first at around let's say age three.
The intra occipital synchondroses is kind of far in the back in the midway point, the
occipital bone, we didn't touch on that during this series but you don't need to know this
per se but it's age four around is when that one closes.
The sphenoethmoi synchondroses closes at around age seven and we mentioned this in the series
that the sphenooccipital is the lagiest synchondroses and this one closes last, late and it could
even be up to age let's say eighteen, there's a pretty long time of that one before it's
closing fully.
So the answer in this one is C and if you want an axial viewpoint this is looking if
we removed the brain and looking straight down at the base of the skull, here's our
sphenoethmoid that's here, the intersphenoid is here, sphenooccipital is the lagiest one,
intraoccipital are back here.
Alright question number eight, a child has a distal step in the primary dentition, which
of the following molar relationships is most likely to develop in the permanent dentition,
go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
Alright so distal step means that we can draw a stair step along the distal surfaces
of the primary of the primary molars.
So this is our distal, this is our mesial and we'll have our, of course we're talking
about steps so we're in the primary dentition phase, we have that upper first primary molar.
So if we were to draw the lower molar down here, well this would be an example of a mesial
step relationship because we can draw a stair step on the mesial side.
If we drew it right underneath, this would be an example of flush terminal plane because
those distal surfaces or the terminal planes are flush to each other.
If we draw the lower molar down here, we have a stair step on the distal side and it can
support a little letter D right there.
And so this is our distal step relationship so we can see that the upper molar is too
far forward relative to the lower molar and that sounds like a class 2 situation.
And it certainly is.
Now if we didn't spend so much time talking about this in our series, you may have guessed
that well this doesn't sound like a very reliable predictive measure.
And that's true for many of the relationships in the primary dentition, not true for the
distal step.
The distal step is almost 100% guaranteed going to be some level of class 2.
So remember when you have a distal step, you almost have a 100% chance, very close to 100%
chance that you're going to end up with some level of class 2 in the permanent dentition.
So the answer here is B.
Alright question number 9, which of the following orthodontic wire materials would be the best
choice for a patient with a nickel allergy?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
Alright, so let's talk through some of these materials.
These are all probably the four most common materials used in orthodontics today.
And so beta titanium also called TMA, which stands for titanium molybdenum alloy.
This does not contain nickel, that I'm kind of giving away the answer here, but that one
does not contain nickel.
Stainless steel does, it contains about 8% nickel and about 18% chromium.
So if it has any amounts of nickel, not great for someone with an allergy.
Nickel titanium of course isn't a good choice, it has nickel in the name.
So that one's out as well, and cobalt chromium also has a small amount of nickel.
So the answer for this one is the only material here that doesn't have any nickel in it and
that's beta titanium.
Okay, question number 10, which of the following conditions presents with glossoptosis, mandibular
retroynophia, and cleft palate?
Go ahead, pause the video and then we'll talk about this one.
Okay, so let's go through these one at a time.
Pieroban sequence involves a sequence of events that leads to the next.
I almost said syndrome, but it is a sequence because it consists of dominoes that kind
of tumble and hit into the next event and the next condition.
So they're all linked together in that way.
Richard Collins syndrome is a syndrome that includes an underdeveloped mandible, which
we have here underdeveloped ears, sometimes cleft palate, which we have here, and downslanted
eyes.
Not sure about glossoptosis though, but we do have two out of the three, so we'll keep
that one in mind.
Hemifacial microsomia is a condition where one side of the face is smaller than the other
affecting the ear and the mandible.
That doesn't really have to do with what we're talking about here, so that one we can
rule out.
And then fetal alcohol syndrome is a syndrome with an underdeveloped mid-face, an increased
chance of cleft lip, not palate, and central nervous system issues.
So fetal alcohol syndrome doesn't match up with what our question is describing.
So treat your Collins, we had two out of the three, not bad, piroband sequence is where
we have a sequence of events, specifically a small mandible early in life, which leads
to backward displacement of the tongue, which is glossoptosis, which interferes with embryological
palate development, often leading to cleft palate.
So one domino leads next in piroband sequence.
The misleading part of this question is that the signs are not in the correct order.
It's this one first, then this one, then this one.
But that can happen on the exam.
So don't let that throw you off, again, be confident in what you know, you know a whole
deal of information.
And so the answer for this one is going to be A.
Question number 11.
Consider the following orthonathic surgery procedures from the lowest to highest chance
of post surgical relapse, and we have maxilla forward, mandible back, and maxilla up.
Go ahead, pause the video, and then we'll go through this one together.
Alright so this is a tough one, and I'm certainly not going easy on you guys in this video.
I know a lot of these questions are on the tougher side, but if you're doing well so
far, stick with it, and keep it up.
So there are multiple steps to this question, and I want to break it down for us real quick.
So lowest to highest chance post surgical relapse, that might be a little bit confusing.
So let's reword that to most stable and predictable to least stable and predictable.
So we have to recall our hierarchy of stability.
And impacting the maxilla, which means moving it up, is one of the most stable movements
that we can make in orthonathic surgery.
So that's going to be towards the early part of our list.
Setting the mandible back is one of the least stable movements that we can make.
So two should be over here, and maxilla forward, a lefort one advancement, is fairly stable
as well, so that might be somewhere in the middle.
So if we could take a stab at this one, we'd want three first, then one, then two last.
And lucky for us, we have three, one, two, and that exact order, and that is the correct
answer.
Here is our hierarchy of stability from most stable and predictable to least stable and
predictable, and that matches up with what we saw in the question.
All right, question number 12, which of the following space analyses predicts mesodistal
width of permanent canines and premolars using a prediction table and a sum of the widths
of the lower incisors?
Go ahead and pause the video, and then we'll talk through this one together.
All right, so let's go through these one at a time and talk about what we know.
So Tanaka Johnston involves the sum of the width of the mandibular incisors, you take
half of that, you plug it into this fancy equation, and that gets you your prediction.
Doesn't involve a table though, so that one is out because that's an important part of
this question.
The Moyers space analysis, you add the width of the mandibular incisors, you take that
sum, and then refer to a prediction table.
Well, that sounds pretty darn good, so we'll keep that one in mind.
Nance and Hickson Oldfather, they might pop up on the exam, their older methods not really
used today anymore, and they used to involve measuring the lower incisors on the cast.
You also evaluate periodical radiographs for part of your estimation, and you might
use a prediction table as well.
So these are involving x-rays, which were not included in the question.
And so we're really left with Moyers being the best answer here involving both a prediction
table and a sum of the widths of the lower incisors.
And these two are going to be the ones that are more than likely going to be the answers
that you're picking from in this kind of question.
So the answer here is B.
Question number 13.
Order the following events that occur when heavy orthodontic force is applied to teeth.
I'll let you read through the rest of these, and then we'll, so you can pause the video
and then we'll talk about this.
Okay, so let's talk through the events for heavy force.
So light force and heavy force are slightly different, so we have to make sure that we're
thinking in our minds that right column that I had in that presentation on biology of tooth
movement and thinking through those rows of events.
So the first thing that happens is the PDL is compressed on the pressure side and is stretched
on the tension side.
So that is certainly going to come first, so we're definitely looking for three being
the first one, I might just scan through the answers, and I'm just going to eliminate those
two.
If I'm taking my test, I'll just right click on those and cross those out.
And then the PDL is going to undergo sterile necrosis, and it's actually going to die
thanks to that heavy force.
And so another word for that is "hylenization."
So one is going to be the next event.
I'm going to go in down here.
Oh, I'm going to rule that one out because I don't see one next.
So this is looking pretty promising.
And then next we're going to have a big delay after this part, and because we have to recruit
osteoclasts from the nearest source, which is going to be the underlying bone marrow,
this is called undermining resorption, which occurs in about three to five days.
So two will be next, okay, that looks good, and then finally the tooth will be able to
move within that remodeled socket in about one or two weeks.
So three, one, two, four, that's looking pretty good, I'm going to select that as our answer,
and that is the correct answer.
All right, so the first day of the part two exam will be 400 questions with these orthodontic
questions, just like the ones we talked about spread throughout that exam.
Then on the second day, you'll come back to do 100 more questions that are case-based.
So you'll get information on a patient with some photos, x-rays, clinical charts.
And then you'll be asked to answer a bunch of questions about that single patient.
So question number 14 and 15 will be examples of questions pertaining to this kind of case-based
thinking.
So we have a 10-year-old child that presents to your clinic in the ugly duckling stage.
The only chief complaint is an unaesthetic space between their two front teeth, and this
diastema is measured at just under two millimeters.
What do you recommend as your preferred treatment option?
So go ahead, pause the video, think through the question, and then we'll talk about this
one.
Okay, so the ugly duckling stage is going to be at around age 10, 11, 12, and that's
where the four permanent incisors are in, in the upper and the lower, but there's this
unappealing space between those two front teeth.
Now, aesthetics is subjective, but quite a few children and their parents can be self-conscious
about that space developing.
If the diastema is less than two millimeters between those upper central incisors, that's
considered normal.
That's a normal stage of dental development.
If it's greater than two millimeters, then we would likely have to intervene at some
point to close that space, but if it's less than two millimeters, mesial eruption of the
maxillary canines should close the space.
And so if we're talking through the answer choices, waiting for the upper canines to erupt
sounds like the perfect thing to do, because that two millimeters may improve in just the
next year or so.
So if we just wait a little bit longer, we won't have to do any kind of treatment, and
that sounds really good to me.
Bonding a two-by-four appliance might be a good option if you're trying to close a space
larger than two millimeters.
The delivering headgear might be for a severe overjet situation.
Bonding full upper and lower in braces is very, I don't want to say aggressive, but that's
a pretty bold treatment plan for a 10-year-old child with a whole bunch of baby teeth still
in their mouth.
So when in doubt, pick the most conservative option.
In this case, the answer is A.
All right, in question number 15, the child has a sister who is eight years old.
She has a unilateral posterior crossbite with a functional shift to the right.
What do you recommend as your preferred treatment?
So go ahead and pause the video, and then we'll go through this last question.
So one of the main indications for phase one early treatment is posterior crossbite with
a functional shift.
And that's because we don't want this to impact their future development, either in
a class three direction or a skeletal asymmetric direction.
So this is an important thing that we want to correct pretty early.
Wait for the full permanent dentition?
No, we actually want to step in and intervene if we could have a preferred and recommended
treatment.
We want to do some kind of phase one.
Reverse pull headgear, that's for a complete underbite with early signs of skeletal class
three.
So we're trying to do some early growth modification.
That's not the case here.
Using a lip bumper, that would be for moderate lower crowding.
Again, that's not what we have here.
A Hyrax expander is exactly what we want.
We want some kind of rapid, palatal expansion to relieve that posterior crossbite.
Even if it's unilateral, we still get, we might get some overexpansion on one side.
But more than likely, they're shifting into that position, and if we can relieve the posterior
crossbite, they will no longer shift to the right, and they will be able to bite together
with CR and MI pretty coincident, that's centric relation and maximum intercussation, coincident
areas.
So if we can get that resolved with a palatal expander, that's the perfect kind of treatment
for this child.
So the answer here is D, an expander to resolve the posterior crossbite.
Alright, and that's it for this video, guys.
Thank you so much for watching.
Please like this video if you enjoyed it, and I sincerely hope you enjoy the orthodontic
series.
It was certainly one of the, one of my favorite ones I've done so far since I just love orthodontic
so much.
Please subscribe to this channel for much more on dentistry, and if you're interested
in supporting this channel and what I do, check out my Patreon page below.
I have an amazing amount of patrons over there.
We have a great community going.
And you can unlock extras like access to these video slides so you can take notes on them
and practice questions for the board exams, go check that out, the link will be in the
description.
Thanks again for watching everyone, and I'll see you in the next video series.